a reality check needs to happen at some
point right exactly otherwise i mean you
can just celebrate something that is not
real
okay let's talk about bob lazar i sent
you an email and i asked you if you had
the time to please watch this video was
a technical explanation of bob lazar in
his younger years did you have a chance
to even skim it
yeah i skimmed it and then i what i
found on on on the web is that
he made a lot of statements without ever
showing any evidence and you know here i
give usually the example of napoleon
you know there were many people over the
years that claimed that they are
napoleon
and
how do you check that once again
experimentally you ask them show me your
id and if they can't show you the idea
that says that they are naporian
and if they keep insisting that they are
napoleon without showing you evidence
for that
you know there are places where you can
put them
and
my point is evidence is the key that's
the way that
science gets credibility that that
that's the way for us to make progress
as i discussed before for us to learn
new things through experiments through
evidence
and it's just it's not just a nuance
uh looking for evidence is not just
something that you can give up on
it's a necessity
that's the only thing that will keep you
sane and making relevant statements
and you can make a lot of statements
that look
bizarre interesting intriguing
emotionally appealing
you know you can make a lot of
statements like that
and in fact our culture is full of that
you have all kinds of myths in our
culture
you know
if
you can think about lots of them i mean
santa
i mean there are lots of needs that are
accepted
uh and they're part of our culture but
they're not regarded as possible you're
crushing me right now i thought santa
claus is real
oh man summarize my point is uh when i
checked a lot of the things he said he
didn't bring um
credible evidence to support them and
that's what makes me worried that
you know and
that
he he is not real
ah i see i see did you take a look at
any of his explanations as to how the
spacecraft would work and is it feasible
in your mind is it
untenable is it
ridiculous
no i mean once again suppose he had a
good idea for making a spacecraft that
we currently do not do not have okay
that nasa is not developing he could
have made a fortune out of it how
very simply instead of talking about it
he could have built it and then it would
fly
what's the problem i mean that's a
straightforward i don't understand why
we need to talk about it even i mean any
reasonable person
that has an idea that is not being used
and that could make uh millions or even
billions of dollars you know first of
all establishes a patent on that and
secondly you know tries to build this
thing
and if it's real he will make that
profit you know
it would be bigger than tesla it would
be bigger than spacex because you would
find a technology that nasa can use
that that nobody thought about so
you know it makes zero sense to say i
know how to do something and not reveal
the details and not build it
if you know how to do it just build it
that's what i tell kids when they come
to me with ideas
okay i believe what he was saying is
that he doesn't know how it works what
happened was he was told
to work on some craft and he believes
they're of alien or extraterrestrial
origin and that the us government knows
how to pilot them to some degree in the
same way that you can learn how to use a
phone or a tablet like they've dropped
phones and
tribes and they know how to turn it on
but they don't know how it works and he
said possibly the way that it works is
with this element called element 115 and
there's a strong nuclear force which
turns into a gravitational force now
that i find interesting i don't know how
it works but to me if that's true that's
that's one way of unifying quantum field
theory with gravity
either way well what do you think about
that
from the point of view of a physicist
this is just nonsense
i mean it makes no sense i i've never
heard about how you turn
the nuclear force into a gravitational
force uh
in any piece of equipment uh of course
if you reach the planck scale you might
be able to do something but you know no
accelerator gets even closer the only
time when we reach that scale perhaps
was at the big bang
or near a singularity of a black hole
but so i i would say this is just not i
mean it makes no scientific sense to me
and
moreover let's imagine that he did not
know the details but someone else
has that equipment why do you think that
someone else will keep it secret why
wouldn't they just use it or develop it
and and you know get a great advantage
relative to others by using it